with its sleek strong body
high-class Mulliner trim and
best-in-class performance the 267,000
Bentley Continental GT Speed convertible
comes pretty close to having it all
we've seen this car before it's actually
just the update to last year's but this
update is worth looking at again for
2015 especially as we move into spring
and into warm weather driving but until
then we've got Bentley signature neck
warmer to keep the chill off the first
thing you'll notice about the car is how
even in smooth its profile is as it
reaches cleanly from its long hood to
the short powerful rear that
uninterrupted line from front to back is
distinctly Bentley so are the carbon
ceramic brakes the diamond lattice girl
and those dark polished LED headlights
the same goes for the handmade interior
embroidered and lumps throughout drilled
alloy pedals and brushed steel accents
it also features diamond quilted leather
seats in a dark bourbon and contrast
stitching complete with heaters and
massagers sea massage is better than a
couple I've had down in Chinatown it's
all very posh finally and I've saved the
best for last
this car has a 626 force power w12
engine that gets to 60 miles per hour in
just over four seconds did I mention
it's the fastest four-seat convertible
in the world
top speed is 203 miles per hour this car
feels better the faster you go at slow
speeds the steering to be honest it's
real loose but when you get up to speed
it feels amazing it feels like you're
just cruising but it's not a car you'll
want to take to the racetrack although
it will more than hold its own there one
press on that gas pedal and you're going
to want to take it down the highway or
through your favorite neighborhood after
all you've got to show off that maybe
you can have it all just about any way